the Senate Judiciary Committee Begins
confirmation hearings this morning for a
Supreme Court nominee who could make
historic changes in the law 53 year old
appeals court judge Brett Kavanaugh has
a record as a solid conservative he'll
be questioned about his views on a wide
range of issues Jan Crawford is inside
the room on Capitol Hill where the
hearing will start in just a few hours
from now Jen good morning well good
morning Nora so today you're going to
see lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
try to frame the debate over Cavanaugh
Republicans say they want to have him
confirm to the bench by the time the
Supreme Court returns that first Monday
in October so they're gonna have to kind
of maintain a united front to fend off
Democrats who are arguing among other
things that Cavanaugh on the bench means
the future of abortion rights is at
stake the candidate that has been named
by Donald Trump was pre-screen by two
right-wing extremist groups Senate
Democrats are gearing up to hammer judge
Brett Kavanaugh on the issues they say
are front and center in this week's
nomination fight one of those groups
[Music]
[Music]
opponents are hoping their message will
convince Republican senators Susan
Collins and Lisa Murkowski both
supporters of abortion rights to vote no
on Cavanaugh we talked about whether
he'd considered road to be settled flaw
he said that it was settled law in
addition to abortion lawmakers are
likely to question Cavanaugh on issues
ranging from affirmative action to
government regulation and executive
authority this is not normal Minnesota
Democrat Amy Klobuchar pointed to the
ongoing investigation into the 2016
election and the White House's refusal
to release every document from
Cavanaugh's time in the Bush
administration as cause for concern
Thanks their did their executive power
148,000 documents that I've seen that
you cannot see
Leonard Leo advises President Trump on
judicial selections as Roe versus Wade
on the table the left has been putting
out the Roe versus Wade scare tactic
since 1982 and nothing's happened to roe
v wade since then now late last night a
lawyer for former president george w
bush released another 40,000 pages of
additional documents from Cavanaugh's
time in the bush White House but that
didn't satisfy a Chuck Schumer who said
that just doesn't give them enough time
to review those records before the
hearing gets underway in a few hours
John John Crawford thank you